good morning josh good morning
schools are changing
whitefield primary school in liverpool
offers children breakfast
free clothing
and help for their families
liverpool's everton ward is one of the
most deprived areas in the country
families here have felt the strain of
austerity
schools like this are trying to cushion
the impact on children
there is an impact upon families who are
on low incomes and may
both parents may be working and still
earning quite a low income and therefore
extras for their children and so on are
hard to come by
this school even has a kitchen and
dining room to create a secure homely
experience
new findings show that schools are
increasingly providing this kind of
extra support
of 2 000 schools surveyed three quarters
were giving pupils extra food
half were providing items of clothing
including underwear and a quarter were
doing laundry for their pupils
teachers are worried that this is
mission creep neither acknowledged nor
funded by central government
every penny spent on welfare in a school
is a penny not spent on education and
every hour a teacher spends on on
providing these sorts of services a time
that they're not teaching or planning
their teaching so i do worry that
schools are picking up the pieces almost
providing a substitute welfare state if
you like to support cuts elsewhere
waterhole primary school in bletchley
supports not just children but their
families too with a full-time family
support worker based inside the school
the school seems to be the first point
of call they haven't got anywhere else
to go first hand they haven't got
anywhere else to go
so we are taking a lot more
problems than we used to
part of the money for this is coming
through the pupil premium a grant for
the poorest pupils which schools can
spend on extra support but is it enough
what we need to take is a more
child-centered approach to policy
generally and not just say well let's
look at schools and hope they can solve
all the problems but look at policies
across a range of areas like health
housing social services and education
and put in place packages around
children that allow them to flourish
low-income working families depend most
on schools for their children's welfare
and that's reality that's likely to
continue whoever wins the election
effort sky news